In Italy, a bridge that was built in the 1960s near Genoa collapsed.
At least 22 people have been reported dead and eight injured.
In the UK, a driver was detained on suspicion of terrorism...
...after crashing his car into a barrier outside of the House of Parliament.
24 people in Ecuador were killed and 19 injured in a bus crash.
Authorities do not know yet what the cause of the accident was.
In Australia, former Archbishop Phillip Wilson is sentenced to a year of prison...
...after concealing child sexual abuse.
Due to his age, he has been allowed to serve his sentence at home.
Finally from Japan,...
...Emperor Akihito will be the first Japanese emperor to abdicate in history.
Akihito spent three decades trying to heal the wounds his father inflicted in World War II,...
...and he will honor the dead one last time.